الحلم طموح والاراده انا منى حسن انا
طبيبه اختصاص اورام ودم واليوم جاي تخبركم
قصتي
[موسيقى]
لما انا كنت خلصت مدرستي وبدي افوت على
كليه الطب اكثر كلمه قالت لي قالت لي اول
شيء بس اخرتكم انا من الفلسطينيين
اللاجئين بلبنان انا خلقت ويرميه بلبنان
ولكن وصلنا في فلسطينيه لاجئه
ولما اتخرست من المدرسه خلصت من اوائل
لبنان كنت معشر الاوائل على لبنان وكنت
كتير حلمي فوتوا بالاهل ما كانوا الصراحه
يعني انا القصه شوي غريبه انه الاهل ما
كان بدهم لانه ولا حدا كان عم بشجعني لانه
ببساطه لانه الطبيب ممنوع يشتغل بلبنان
اذا انت طبيبي منك لبنانيه
[موسيقى]
سالته سؤالي كثير واضح وسريع قلت له
بدي اسالك سؤال حضرتك انت اخترت انك تولد
بالجنسيه اللي هو كان فيها قال لي لا قلت
له حضرتك اخترت تولد لاهلك قال لي لا قلت
له احترت تولد بالمحل اللي انتم ولدت فيه
قال لي لا قلت له اذا هو ثلاثه اسئله انت
بتجاوبنا علي ولا لا على اساس شو انت بدك
اياني انه انا مستقبله ومصيري اساس شيء
انا ما كان عندي سيطره عليه وعلى اساس هذا
الشيء انا فتت الحمد لله على كليته الطوب
ووقتها
لانه كنت متطابقين لبنان وانا هلا اتخرجت
همم طبيب عامه بامتياز وهلا همم خلصت
امراض باطنيه الاختصاص الاول وهلا حاليا
عم بشتغل كحكيمه همم او عم بتخصص كحكيمه
اورام همم لمرضى السرطان واكثر شيء عم جرب
ركز عليه وانه ده سرطان اللاجئين للاسف
شريحه كبيره همم من المجتمع اللاجئ السوري
الفلسطيني همم موجود الدول العربيه هم مثل
مواليد تاني هن اشخاص بيعانوا من كانسر هن
اشخاص بيمرضوا ولكن للاسف مجرد انه هن
يصنف ولاجئين ما في عندهم هيدا همم القدره
على الوصول الى العلاج ياللي نحنا همم
لازم نعطيه او يمكن تقوله انه هذا حلم
كثير بعيد بس انا اذا في شيء تعلمته بكل
حياته انه اول شيء همم ما تقول مستحيل
عايشين لانه دائما دائما بيظلوا في امان
دائما في شيء فينا نعمله همم ثاني شيء انه
ما بحياتك تقول لا لا فرصه ثم كانت هذه
الفرصه لانه ما بتعرف هي الفرصه لوين
هتوصل لك انا اذا كنت بدي اقول انه انا
لاجئه همم كل شيء ضدي كل الحياه ضدي وقف
ما كنت راح تشوفوني هون اليوم بس انا قلت
ما في ايامات كانت
الدكتوره العالم
ولايك وشو ما اكلت الصعوبات شو ما كانت
التحديات راح تقدروا توصل لهذا الشيء هذه
هي النقطه النهائيه
[موسيقى]